In this tutorial, we'll discuss
upper arm size and set in sleeves.
Like ready-made clothing, commercial
sweater patterns are created based on a
set of standards.
What if you aren't standard size?
We covered lengthening and shortening
sleeves in a previous tutorial.
Let's consider changing the upper arm
and the impact on the sleeve head.
Imagine how uncomfortable this purple
sweater must be to where there's no ease
and the knitting is stretched
over the model's upper arm.
This can often be an issue when it in plus
size sweaters and for men's sweaters as
well.
The sleeve head indicated by the yellow
line must match the armhole opening.
In classic dress making the sleeve head
has a bit of ease, but for this example,
we'll just ignore the ease.
Now what happens if you just make
the upper arm of the sleeve larger?
The sleeve head is enlarged and it's
no longer going to fit in the arm hole.
We don't want to alter
the depth of the arm hole.
We just want to add
fullness over the upper arm.
Let's picture a paper pattern.
We can slash that paper pattern and spread
the upper arm to the proper dimension.
Now if we stop here again, the
sleeve head's going to be too large.
But by dropping down the top of the sleeve
head redrawing the shape will accomplish
what we need for our sleeve to fit, and
the sleeve head will still match the arm
hole opening.
One thing to notice is that
the cuff size is also enlarged.
If you do this, and you may not want that,
you can always alter the size of the cuff
and recalculate the underarm shaping.
Let's continue with the sleeve head.
Now let's look at this another way.
We'll take the curves out
of the equation for now.
The initial bind offs won't change and the
final bind offs are not going to change.
All we're going to do is reshape the
sleeve head in the area shown by the
yellow line.
Once again, we'll make
the upper arm wider.
I'll just rotate that yellow line and it's
clear that the sleeve head's going to be
too large, so what we need to do
is drop that final bind off area.
So the length of the yellow line remains
the same and the sleeve head will fit into
the arm hole.
Here's another thing to notice.
Not only is the upper arm of the sleeve
wider, but the shape of the sleeve head
changes as well on the purple sweater.
The model could use more fabric.
Across her top of her arm.
Changing the shape of the sleeve head
would greatly improve the fit of this
sweater.
Okay.
Now we understand the issues
surrounding modifying a set in sleeve.
What we've done is fine
for a paper sewing pattern.
You just redraw a nice curve and you're
all set as long as the sleeve had
measurement and matches
the armhole opening.
Now what about knitting?
In our next tutorial, we'll talk about
different methods for drafting the sleeve
head for knitting.